warning the following video may contain
graphic puppet on puppet violence viewer
discretion is advised
hold on to your heads because we have
the greatest show about puppets yes it's
been 37 years since Jim Henson's the
Dark Crystal terrified an entire
generation of children a Netflix has
spared no expense in this modern-day
version my god in this video we're going
to be taking a deep dive into the Dark
Crystal Age of resistance it's ending
and what it could mean for season 2 so
grab your duel glaives because here we
go the dark crystals climax deals
predominantly with the clash between the
Skeksis and gelfling 'he's Rhian who's
voiced by the Kingsmen 'he's Taron
Egerton tries to calm deep before the
impending battle but deep turns away
from him after they hold hands this is a
bit weird since they almost got it on a
few episodes ago I think you're wrong
traces
[Music]
but knowing what happened too deep last
episode you can see why she turned away
in Episode eight the sanctuary tree
passed on its powers to deat after nur
Locke's wit succumbed to the darkening
ate away at him as the sanctuary tree
said the darkening cannot be destroyed
like all energy it can only be
transferred this idea of transferring
energy is pivotal to the lore of the
dark crystal and will come into play
more later on in the episode it's also
important to note that when deep took on
the sanctuary trees power she
experienced glimpses of the future and
these glimpses offer us valuable clues
as to what might happen in season two
for example we have this image of Dietz
sitting on the Skeksis emperor's throne
likely hinting that she may switch sides
if the darkening takes too big a hold
over her we also get this shot of a
mother perhaps it's Bria holding a child
which is a throwback to the 82 Dark
Crystal hinting that Brea gives birth to
either Jen or Keira from that film now
this is a good time to say that if you
haven't seen my video on the 1982 film
I'll leave a link in the description
because I go into great detail over the
lore of the Skeksis mystics and the last
of the gelfling I've never heard of The
Shard but moving on in the background we
get our first glimpse of the Garthim who
we see make an appearance at the end of
episode 10 in age of resistance we
essentially get their origin story
learning that the scientists created
them using a combination of Erath m and
grunick parts we get this shot which
seems to be a recreation of the 1982
climax where the gelfling gen puts the
crystal shard piece into the crystal of
truth but the weird thing is unlike the
real version gen is the only one here
there should be Skeksis everywhere
finally we get this close-up of DEET
affected by the darkening which we'll
see become a reality at the end of the
season this prophecy however shouldn't
be taken at face value since the title
of this episode is called prophets don't
know everything so what we're seeing
isn't necessarily set in stone going
back earlier in the episode we'll see
this purple energy course through
vanes she doesn't want to touch rien
because she's afraid it may transfer to
him not because she's disinterested oh
and before I forget deep is voiced by
Natalie Immanuel from Game of Thrones
this is not going to end well meanwhile
in the crystal castle the emperor has a
trick up his sleeve for the upcoming
battle he's been able to harness part of
the darkening power through a crystal
affixed to his scepter it's important to
note here how the dark name came about
in the first place years ago a battle
between the Mystics and the Skeksis
resulted in a shard from the crystal of
truth being broken off this imbalance
slowly started the darkening a process
which has rapidly been growing since the
Skeksis started draining the gelfling z'
of their essence i beg you to reconsider
the more essence weakened soul that weak
as the crystal grows the greater the
imbalance the faster the darkening
spread da but why exactly do the Skeksis
need the gelfling essence why now
well since the corruption of the crystal
of truth its energy which the Skeksis
have been feeding off of has been
growing weaker the more they take from
the crystal the less it gives tomorrow
we take this is why the scientist has
been tasked with finding a new method of
immortality a method which is later
tried on its first test subject mira
back in stone would Rhian prepares for
battle by sharpening his dual clave the
ancient weapon according to sketch gras
and ago that can stop the Skeksis were
good this glaive was forged in the
deepest fires of the inner Sun and
carries the spirit of thraw when wielded
by gelfling
holds the power to unite the seven clans
Rhian was able to gather the two pieces
of the glaive one was hidden inside
Madra argot staff while the other was
put inside the crucible in stone wood
the glaive also happened to last be
wielded by Rian's father or Don in the
great battle between gelfling x' and the
heir 'litham a battle which ironically
was won with the help of the Skeksis
this is how the ascendancy was cast out
from the caves of Krotz and how that
land was later given to the gelfling x'
in a pep talk to the resistance Rhian
explains
i'm done with running stand before i run
again one of the recurring themes
ferrari in this season was running away
some may even call it cowardice when
mirror was being drained he ran when
gurchin was captured he ran his father
sacrificed himself so he could run away
but not this time
the scientist having been ordered to
stay at the castle away from battle
tries his hand at sitting on the throne
when the hunter comes back to life last
episode's attempt to infuse the hunter's
body with Aguas essence seems to have
worked and the irony that he's held up
like a puppet here isn't lost on us as
well later find out Aras sacrifice was
all part of her plan but it also
completes a Redemption arc Audra feels
responsible for the Skeksis ah's
takeover of thraw she was the one who
gave the Skeksis the crystal of truth in
exchange for the orrery this mechanical
model of the solar system she spent
years searching the cosmos and learning
from the technology given to her by the
Skeksis that it was only when thrall was
facing great harm that she was awoken
from her dreamlike state agra offers her
life in exchange to free the gelfling x'
but if there's anything we know about
the Skeksis it's that they almost always
go back on their word Brants ella didn't
make up even though Selatan should
probably be tried for war crimes we then
get to the major battle this entire
season has building up - which starts
with the general taking on rien and his
duel clave the general is ultimately
stabbed by Rhian but here's the
interesting thing what appears to be the
generals essence or at least part of it
is sucked into the crystal of the duel
clave now the general doesn't die here
it only happens a bit later when the
Chamberlain does the
so it's uncertain whether this energy
transference was fully complete
regardless this is some definite season
to set up and the power of the crystal
char to transfer energy will undoubtedly
come into play next season perhaps even
helping transfer the darkness from DEET
another big question mark is if the
general is actually dead he's alive in
the 1982 movie which is set after the
events of age of resistance so it's
entirely possible that this energy
transference was successful and some
part of the general lives within that
crystal how he'll come back to life is
anyone's guess but with Agua coming back
from the dead anything is possible
also did Bree and just forget about his
girlfriend Mira awkward we get a better
look at the crystal shard after Brea
picks it up from the shattered dual
clave this is the same crystal shard Jen
will use in the movie to heal the
crystal of truth and the same one which
will come into the possession of agra
after the gelfling genocide in the
battle the hunter grabs Rhian and
destroys the dual blade but before he
can finish the job on rien archer the
hunter's mystic opposite kills himself
thus killing the hunter again if you
want to know more about how this process
works check out my other Dark Crystal
video with the hunter killed augers
essence is reborn and the seven clans of
the gelfling show up in the nick of time
to take on the Skeksis not only that but
the era thumb have also joined their
side after they found out that they were
double-crossed by the Skeksis who gave
them back the cave of grot only to find
that it was infested with darkness with
no alternative the emperor uses his
staff which contains the power of the
darkening which DEET is able to hold off
and ultimately blow awkwafina's head off
this causes the Skeksis to run away in
fear with the battle one a few questions
remain as to what will happen next
season chiefly among them what the heck
has happened to deat we see her walk off
into the distance away from rien likely
for his own good she's infected as is
evidenced by the dying plants around her
and likely doesn't want anyone around
her my guess is that the only thing
preventing her from being overtaken by
the darkness was the power given to her
by the sanctuary tree we also don't know
if Saladin will remain the al mandra
after what she put her people through
HUP seems to have found the yellow
trinket which is able to conjure lore so
we'll probably see more of that in
season two and like
descendants to a full-on paladin the
final scene however looks pretty grim
for the Skeksis they're petrified that
their days are numbered
until the scientists reveals his newest
creation the Garthim the Garthim army
was used in the Dark Crystal movie to
undertake the annihilation of the
gelfling x' so season 2 will likely see
them building this army up and utilizing
it there's also the question of the
crystal shard that Brea picks up and how
it eventually gets into the hands of
Agra along with several other fake
crystals the Skeksis will eventually
find out about this shard and hide fake
ones to throw the golfing's off we also
haven't visited the ruins which Jen and
Kira find in the movie the ones that
reveal to them the prophecy that will
lead to the downfall of the Skeksis plan
on finding more about this next season
but I want to hear your thoughts about
this truly awesome season in the
comments below if you haven't already
please do check out my other Dark
Crystal video make sure to LIKE and
subscribe with the Belon because I have
more breakdown videos on the horizon you
can also feel free to follow me on
twitter at things story whitey and until
next time remember daddy loves you very
much